- La dernière fois que
vous avez vu François Lega
sur la COVID, c'était
le 8 février, il y a six mois.
- Aujourestions sur
des sujets autres que ce qui
concerne la santé publique.
- Sa visres
à la veille de la campagne
électorale, juge son équipe.
Au contraire, sa présence est
nécessaire après avoir entendu
du genre...
- Moi, j'ai eu mes trois doses
en ce moment puis
- J'ai déjà mes deux
puis ça va être assez!
- Le premier ministre veut
les convaincre d'aller chercher
leur 4e dose dès la semaine
prochaine.
- Faut se protéger,
faut protéger les autres!sssssss
à partir du 22 août.
Une semaine plus tard,
tous les adultes pourront
l'obtenir, juste à temps
pour la rentrée scolaire.Françoi
régler la question de
la vaccination massive avant
son marathon électoral.
- (Sébastien Bovet):
ue vous craignez pas
que le gouvernement prenne pas
les décisions importantes
qu'il doit prendre en regarden e
puis qu'il veut pas déplaire
à la po
SYLVAIN LÉVESQUE,
député CAQ de Chauveau
- Non, absolument pas.rs priori.
M. Dubé a toujours priorisé
la santé des Québé
- Les députés caquistes
insistent sur l'indépendance
de la santé publiq
Toutes les recommandations
seront suivies, quitte à p
des points de popularité.
MARGUERITE BLAIS,
- On a vu que le gouvernement
a été capable aussi d'annoncer
des réparations àrations àratio-
Lafontaine avant les élections,
donc ça s'appelle
- Mais pour l'instant, ils
rappellent qu'aucune restriction
Avant de se rendre jusque-là,
Québec va d'abord rouvrir les
grands centres de vaccination,
comme le stade olympique,
300 000 personnes par semaine.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre, Santé
et Services sociaux du Québec
sont mises
en place, qui sont en train
de tout être finalisées.
- Ceux qui n'ont pas contracté
ou reçu de vaccin
depuis au moins 5 mois devraient
sérieusement envisager la dose
ALAIN LAMARRE, spécialiste
en immunovirologie
- C'est un virus qui mute
beaucoup et qui arrive
aire.
- François Legault veut
affaiblir la 8e vague que
la santé publique
devenir son adversaire si,
comme premier mitant,
il la gère mal alors qu'il est
en campagne électorale
comme ch Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio-Canada, Qué